all right let's get right into it very
important 2022 race fetterman versus Oz
Pennsylvania Senate television quack Dr
Mehmet Oz is the Republican Senate
nominee in Pennsylvania running against
him as the Democratic Lieutenant
Governor John fetterman much has been
made by the Oz people about fetterman
having a stroke and fetterman uh needing
special medical accommodations for
debates and all of these horrible
different things and increasingly Oz has
just looked really like a bad guy and
there is a new poll that looks very bad
for Mehmet Oz but we try to pay
attention to the average of recent polls
and never Focus too much on any one poll
but let's go in order new poll
fetterman ahead of Oz with a
double-digit lead writes Newsweek
when you look at the details this is a
new Marist poll published earlier this
week 51 percent of registered voters in
Pennsylvania support fetterman compared
to 41 percent who support Oz 7
undecided this is a good number for
fetterman however if you go to likely
voters I'm sorry definite voters in
November Oz gets 44 with fetterman 51
and 4 percent undecided however when we
look at the averages of recent polls you
see that fetterman's lead is an average
of four and a half points
again we want to see this as glass glass
half full or do we want to see this as
glass half empty and the questions are
always very similar well the glass half
full perspective is
fetterman's winning and it's outside the
margin of error the glass half empty is
how on Earth
does a TV doctor from a different state
who has no business even running never
mind being in the Senate have an average
of 44 of the expected Pennsylvania
electorate saying yeah I'm gonna go with
the quack TV doctor from Jersey
glass half full glass half empty you
tell me the important thing is assume
absolutely nothing and make sure that
you vote there are important deadlines
in Pennsylvania the deadline for
in-person registration at local election
offices is October 24th that's three and
a half weeks away
uh the deadline to register online is
October 24th and the deadline to
register by mail is your request must be
received by October 24th so October 24th
is the important number in Pennsylvania
now for absentee ballots you must
request your ballot no later than
November 1 by 5 PM it must be received
your return ballot by mail meaning when
you vote must be received November 8th
by 8 PM that's when polls close in
Pennsylvania if you don't send it early
enough for it to be received by that
time
it's not going to be counted and then
lastly to turn in your ballot in person
or vote in person it is November 8th by
8 PM polls close 8 pm on Election Day in
Pennsylvania
extraordinarily important election when
we ask the question as many of us often
do
on which state might Democratic control
of the Senate hinge one of the most
likely outcomes is that if indeed
Democratic control hinges on only one
state that state will be Pennsylvania so
these midterms
we never want to say races don't matter
of course tons of races matter but both
gubernatorially and senatorially
Pennsylvania is dramatically important I
hope all of our Pennsylvania listeners
are registered or you're going to get
registered by October 24th and you're
going to vote not only is the Senate
vote important but I will again take the
opportunity to remind you the
gubernatorial race and we will be
covering a debate between Shapiro and
mastriano
the Republican nominee in Pennsylvania
for the Governor's race Doug mastriano
yes he has a history of dressing like a
confederate soldier it's disgusting yeah
he's vile disgusting guy fine but put
that aside for a second
he is overtly
a guy who will try to steal Pennsylvania
for the Republican presidential
candidate in 2024 no matter who wins he
has said he was in DC on January 6th he
has said he believes Trump actually won
in Pennsylvania even though he didn't he
didn't get more votes but somehow
mastriano thinks Trump won
if in 2024
you have a tight election in
Pennsylvania and the Democratic
Presidential nominee wins if mastriano
is the governor he will try to steal
those electoral votes for the Republican
even if the Republican didn't win I
don't know how else to say it I don't
know how else to explain it to people
this is an emergency in Pennsylvania
I think I've said enough register
make sure you know where your polling
place is do not forget to vote this is
an unbelievable story
the Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton
fled his home in a truck to avoid being
handed a subpoena imagine the imagery of
this CNBC has a good and simple and
straightforward write-up of this Texas
AG Ken Paxton fled home with his wife to
avoid a subpoena in an abortion case
according to a court filing released
earlier this week Texas Attorney General
Ken Paxton allegedly fled his home with
his wife to avoid being served a
subpoena according to a sworn affidavit
The subpoena ordered the Republican
attorney general to appear and testify
in a civil lawsuit in which multiple
texas-based non-profits want to resume
helping pregnant residents obtain
abortions in other states a federal
judge quashed The subpoena Paxton on
Twitter claimed he was showing concern
for his family and later said that the
process server the process server is the
individual who delivers the subpoena is
lucky this situation did not escalate
further that's a quote
packs look at these details Paxton ran
from the garage or garage of some say
Paxton ran from the garage of his home
in McKinney Texas into a truck driven by
his wife state senator Angela Paxton
while refusing to accept the documents
from a process server according to the
affidavit filed in court the paxtons
drove away without taking the documents
which were left on the ground by the
house according to the process server
federal judge Robert Pittman granted a
motion Tuesday to quash The subpoena
Paxton argued The subpoena was
unwarranted because none of the
requisites for making or enforcing such
a demand have been satisfied in a
statement Tuesday Paxton accused the
server of posing a threat by charging
Adam and yelling unintelligibly
oh my goodness this is the guy who was
indicted for felony Securities fraud
charges uh years ago
hasn't faced consequences hasn't been
put on trial
uh he still won his Republican primary
and remember as long as it's not a
Democrat Republican voters don't care
what these people do they claim to be
for Law and Order part of Law and Order
is listen
uh illegally created and obtained
subpoena
delivered by a process server a
legitimate process server
and you just run away and jump into a
truck and drive away
that's not Law and Order and again the
Law and Order crowd adhering to the
principle of well Law and Order for
everybody else this is a characteristic
of authoritarianism there is no rules
for the Insiders and the cronies and as
I read this story and as I think about
the perspective of these individuals on
what Law and Order means to them and I
don't mean to them for society I mean to
them when they are the ones involved
with the judicial system it really is
reminiscent of Putin's Russia
and
there's a cartoonish nature for sure
here of Paxton running away and jumping
you know it's Texas he probably had a
belt buckle that was huge and he runs
and jumps into a pickup truck I get it
the imagery is cartoonish the imagery is
funny to some degree but the real story
here is the authoritarian nature of Law
and Order for everybody else and in fact
using the justice system and law
enforcement to their advantage as tools
when it's for other people
and then when it comes to them they just
say no it was a little illegitimate or
I'm going to jump into a truck and run
away it's really the same thing with the
Trump search warrant at Mar-A-Lago which
is hey you know what we back the blue
The Thin Blue Line support the police
except when it's the capitol police at
the Trump riots well in that case it was
the protesters by which you know they
mean Riders who are actually the heroes
and oh no support law enforcement are
great all these great people
they get a legal search warrant signed
off on by the Attorney General by the
FBI director by a judge they go to
Trump's house and they get the stuff
that they're entitled to get oh no no no
no no now it's not about support law
enforcement now it's law enforcement has
been weaponized by Biden even though
Biden had nothing to do with that search
warrant that's the theme and it's an
authoritarian theme that we should all
be very careful about and very scared of
legitimately it's not a slippery slope
thing it's
we should be scared now because of how
they are willing to abandon every single
one of these principles as soon as it's
inconvenient to them as soon as it comes
down on them so Ken Paxton uh jumping
into a truck and running away Beyond
parody but they're for Law and Order
don't don't forget that guys they're for
Law and Order let me know your thoughts
you can find me on Twitter at dpacman we
are going to take a very quick break and
be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David pakman show is an audience
supported program we are an independent
media program we don't have some big
corporate entity that funds us and
staffs us up with dozens of producers
doing almost nothing I've seen it
firsthand folks no we have a small team
everybody has multiple roles and many
responsibilities and were primarily
funded by our viewers and our podcast
listeners and our radio audience I would
love for you to add your name to our
list of supporters by signing up at
joinpakman.com it's quick it's easy it's
painless it comes with great perks
including an extra show every single day
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for you as well as
members only Town Halls where we invite
our website members to call in and talk
to me ask me your questions tell me your
stories
Etc sign up at joinpakman.com and you
can use the coupon code Obama Obama
that's o b a m n a to get a serious
discount off of the cost of your
membership I know when I tell you the
following headline many of you will say
is this a rerun David is this a 2020
episode or a 2021 episode no it is
almost October of 2022.
and 61 percent of Republicans
still think that Donald Trump actually
won the 2020 presidential election it is
almost October of 2022. Monmouth poll
shows according to NBC news that nearly
a third of all Americans including six
in ten Republicans continue to hold the
debunked belief that President Joe Biden
did not win the 2020 election
legitimately this is a new Monmouth
University poll released the day before
the January 6 committee was going to
hold a hearing because of the hurricane
the January 6 committee has canceled
today's hearing just as an FYI
29 of all respondents as well as 61
percent of Republicans say that Joe
Biden won due to voter fraud
due to voter fraud
can you imagine these numbers have been
relatively consistent over time if you
look at the chart you see that late in
2020 and throughout most of 2021 about
32 percent of all Americans believed
Biden won due to voter fraud that is
down just slightly in 2022 to 29
these are incredible numbers that the
world sees and says what the hell is
going on in the United States and they
are right to ask that question
you really
oh how do you share a country
and how do you run a government
split with individuals who believe the
system only works when they win that's
fundamentally what this is you know many
of you wrote to me after my interview
yesterday with Republican candidate
Allison Hayden the interview was a
complete mess complete and total mess
um she's running against Eric swalwell
in California our friend Eric swalwell
who by the way I obviously Support
swalwell over Allison Hayden in that
race in case I didn't make it completely
clear during the interview and people
wrote to me and said you know David an
interesting question to ask folks like
this people like Allison Hayden who say
no no no no if you can't trust the the
election results
would they be flipping out the way
they've been flipping out about voter
fraud and election Integrity since
November of 2020. would they be doing
the same thing if the results had shown
Trump had won because they claim that
their concern is not about who won that
their concern is about the process as I
lose my earpiece here due to excitement
they say the concern is about the
process and the handling of the ballots
and the Integrity of how everything was
handled
would they be behaving the same way if
it had been Donald Trump who had won
Under the exact same circumstances and
of course we all know the answer and
that gets us down to this very again I
know we use this it's like five times a
show we get to this point this is
extraordinarily authoritarian the system
can be trusted when I've won
and when I've lost it is a systemic
problem that we need to fix now there's
probably some imagine a Venn diagram the
people who believe Trump won in 2020 and
the people who believe that Barack Obama
was not really born in the United States
my guess is there's a pretty significant
overlap between those two groups and it
really shows the power of endlessly
repeating a lie
to some degree
some of that 61 percent you and I know
they don't literally believe that Donald
Trump won in November of 2020 but it's a
combination of other things some of the
61 percent that are saying I believe
Trump won
say it because it signals membership in
a team and we've talked about this
before you have to show that you're part
of the team and you show that by saying
Donald Trump actually is the winner of
the 2020 election others have a
cognitive dissonance where they simply
can't admit even to themselves they were
Bamboozled by a very mediocre charlatan
that's what happened and the way that
they avoid admitting that to themselves
is by saying oh the guy actually won the
guy I supported actually is the winner
and so there's a lot of group psychology
at play there's a lot of magical
thinking there's a lot of non-thinking
at Play
but it's all extremely demoralizing when
we say Hey you know we should at least
be able to agree on some basis of fact
here and unfortunately we can't do that
61 percent of Republicans don't believe
Joe Biden won the 2020 election this is
a really interesting uh sign
a whole bunch of Republicans who won
their 2022 primaries wiped
uh mentions a failed former president
Donald Trump from their websites after
their primary as they reset their
campaigns for the general election in
November this signals an arguably
significant change within the Republican
electorate at least as far as the
candidates are perceiving so let's talk
about it there's a good Daily Beast
article by Sam Brody who's a
congressional reporter which points out
and is titled Republican candidates
strip abortion and Trump connections
from their campaign websites these
Republicans have made a calculation they
made the calculation during the primary
among the Republican electorate it's
good to play up our connection to Trump
and our our support of Donald Trump once
they won their primary their view
changed and they said okay for the
general election electorate I am now
better off removing mentions of Donald
Trump and I think when we look at
exactly who these candidates are it will
start to make a lot of sense and we're
going to link to this article and you
can check it out uh and I'm getting a
paywall and uh let me just see if I can
deal with that so that we can actually
look at the article that popped up all
of a sudden and because of clarity I
really want to uh here we go okay right
after Beau Heinz won a crowded primary
from Congress in North Carolina
a visitor to the campaign website would
immediately find his declaration that he
was 100 pro-life and 100 pro-trump
pretty clear
a click away was a section focused on
life and family which professed Heinz
position that life begins at conception
naturally the first thing greeting any
visitor to the site was the grinning
face of trump and it is all gone gone
gone
and the article points out that all of
that stuff all of those invocations and
images of Donald Trump they've all been
removed except for one apparently
photoshopped image with Heinz in the
section on border security this is not
the first person who did this The Daily
Beast reviewed a bunch of different
websites for 2022 Republican candidates
and found that at least five house
Republican candidates in Battleground
districts completely wiped or scrubbed
mentions of trump or the 2020 election
from their websites or social media
right after winning the primaries at
least seven removed or significantly
modified language about abortion on
their websites over the summer
at least three have scrubbed their
online pages of trump that includes
Blake masters of Arizona Mehmet Oz of
Pennsylvania Tiffany Smiley of
Washington and at least two did the same
for abortion Blake Masters and Adam
laxalt so as the article says generally
it's uncommon to see Cam that it
significantly changed Platforms in
branding during the course of a campaign
some of them are saying well we just
redirect we just redesigned the website
that's all we did others are saying well
we reshuffled the content to other
places but we know exactly what is going
on here there is a recognition among
many of these Republican candidates that
number one the Hardline anti-abortion
positions are out of step with the
American public we know that
all polling shows us that over the last
50 years what we call the Roe v Wade era
over the period of the Roe v Wade era
the country has moved in the direction
of abortion being illegal to those who
want it in most cases and this really
came to a head with the Supreme Court's
reversal of Roe v Wade with guaranteed
abortion as a right in most cases to
women
this is now causing a problem for some
Republicans and the way some of them are
dealing with it is getting rid of the
hardcore anti-choice language from their
websites but there's a second bigger
recognition as well the guy that will
help you win among the Republican
electorate may actually hurt you in the
general election and we're talking of
course of Donald Trump this is to some
degree a change from previous years you
know we often laugh about Trump takes
credit for his endorsement record and
that record really isn't quite as good
as he claims it to be but the truth is
that it was pretty good for a while and
it no longer is seen as the sort of
unabashed advantage that it was at one
point we will see how these folks do in
November uh and then we will see what
that means for 2024. hurricane Ian may
be making landfall in Florida quite
literally as we speak I hope every one
of our viewers in the areas that are
getting hit and we have a lot of viewers
in those areas are
um heeding the precautions evacuating if
you've been indicated that if it's been
indicated that you should evacuate Fox
News propagandist Tucker Carlson is
saying that hurricanes are a scam
we're going to take a look at a clip of
Tucker's show from last night let's take
a listen
so you hate to Hype hurricanes because
it's just a staple of TV and everyone's
kind of onto the skin but there's a
legitimately large hurricane barreling
toward the Gulf Coast of Florida tonight
hurricane bigger than we've seen in more
than 100 years before most hurricane
predictor in this country many people
Vie for the title but this man may take
it joins us after the break yeah so
listen I I don't know whether Tucker is
saying that worrying about hurricanes is
generally a scam or that the media
coverage of the hurricane industrial
complex is a scam
but it is genuinely scary that fox
news's business model in many ways is
tell our viewers that they are being
lied to about lots of different things
that will actually keep them safer right
don't get the vaccine
don't take precautions on covid there's
no climate change hurricanes are a scam
now the most charitable interpretation
of what Tucker Carlson is saying here is
the way that media Outlets
spend days covering hurricanes sending
reporters to stand in the wind and the
rain and the entire thing the disaster
porn videos that that is a scam
that would be the most charitable
interpretation of what Tucker is saying
and if that's the case his own network
is one of the greatest perpetrators of
that very scam because Fox News does it
all the time they will do the 24 7
hurricane coverage just like everybody
else so it's never really clear what
Tucker Carlson is saying and this is
kind of part of his game to always use
sort of coded language or to kind of
dance around issues in some way it's not
exactly clear what he means that the
scam is but the theme Here is Fox News
participates in whatever scam he's
talking about just as much as everybody
else and if you exclusively get your
news from Fox News you are more likely
to be receiving suggestions implicit or
explicit that you engage in behavior
that is quite literally putting your
life at risk and that is wacky we will
have all of these clips on our Instagram
make sure you're following us at
davidpackman show we will take a quick
break and be back to cover the growing
Republican Civil War as we get closer to
2024 Stay With Me
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's briefly discuss the growing very
explosive Civil War within the
Republican party this is already a fight
for the 2024 Republican nomination it is
Trump versus DeSantis both are in glass
houses and throwing many many many
stones let's start with Trump on
DeSantis and then we will look at
DeSantis on Trump on the Trump side
Donald Trump is flipping out and
recently called Ron DeSantis fat phony
and whiny which sounds
extraordinarily like projection let's
discuss it Maggie Haberman has a new
book coming out and she wrote an article
about her interviews for the book for
the Atlantic now I know it listened it's
always the same routine all of these
folks they have all the good stuff and
they hold it for their books in order to
sell books it's what it is doesn't mean
that uh any of it is untrue they all do
it and Bolton did it they all did it we
talk about it is it immoral to some
degree yeah maybe I mean here these are
not uh claims about with National
Security implications but we all know
that they do this in the article in the
Atlantic three conversations with Donald
Trump
there is a section about Rhonda Santos
and Maggie Haberman writes I brought up
another potential future primary rival
by mentioning that he had been compared
to New Jersey's feisty Governor Chris
Christie before the two men faced off in
the 2016 primary Trump replied I was
compared to him why I didn't know I had
that big of a weight problem a small
smirk followed then he's an opportunist
I heard that Trump was describing
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis in similar
terms calling him fat
phony and whiny while claiming credit
for making his candidacy in 2018.
um what is with Trump and calling
everyone fat Bill Barr recently called
him fat Chris Christie recently posted
of a picture of a guy at a buffet it's
still not even clear to me whether it
was Chris Christie or not it looks like
Chris Christie but I don't know if it
was and now Ron DeSantis and the
projection is truly incredible and I
think it goes to Trump's insecurities
Trump is obese okay Trump is obese Trump
claims to be
632-39 he's not six three and he weighs
more than 239 and according to BMI which
is not a perfect measure but I think
it's it's more or less right with Trump
trump is obese Trump is a total phony
he says the santis is a phony Trump
developed a fake persona to run as a
republican Trump was for abortion access
for 68 years of his life
and then he decided he's going to run
for president and he said no no I'm very
very pro-life as he describes it uh and
the story he came up with is you know I
met a woman
and I met the woman's kid
and the woman told me I once thought
about getting an abortion but now I have
this great kid and Trump said wow I
liked the kid so much I became against
abortion come on guys Trump's claims to
be religious he's a complete and total
phony which he accuses Ron DeSantis of
being and I've never seen a bigger
whiner than Donald Trump I I I I cannot
think of in the political world bigger
whiners than the Trump family we're the
poor most poorly treated people ever I
was the best president and everyone says
mean things they're all going after me
they're mean all this different stuff
and what we are starting to see here
with Trump and DeSantis as you're going
to see in a moment is that narcissism is
colliding with more narcissism and you
can get some really interesting results
and we may indeed have that in the 2024
Republican primary if both of these guys
run now the numbers in the 24 Primary in
the betting markets have completely
reversed in Ron DeSantis favor and I'm
going to get to that in a moment but now
that we've covered the Trump on DeSantis
part of the Republican Civil War let's
go to the DeSantis on Trump part of the
Civil War
I want the 2024 Republican primary to
become the dirtiest
filthiest most corrupt and disgusting
mud-slinging Fest that we can imagine
because it will be bad for republicans
in 2024 and we already read of trump
going after Ron DeSantis as being fat
and phony and whiny but Ron DeSantis is
also now going after Donald Trump
there's a great article by Gabriel
Sherman in Vanity Fair Gabriel Sherman
is very good at these types of Articles
the article is called Ron DeSantis the
making and remaking and remaking of a
Maga air with the subtitle the Florida
governor is the fox loving lib owning
successor in waiting to Donald Trump's
cult of personality but for all
desantises Bona fides and rocketing
National profile doubts about his own
Persona calculated aloof cold-blooded
persist is it anyone wonder he and the
former president are already locked in a
2024 Cold War
the article explains
that behind the scenes
Ron DeSantis is not a big fan of Donald
Trump and I have to tell you
Ron DeSantis is not a dumb guy I think
Ron DeSantis is completely depraved
morally ethically and his willingness to
take on the Persona that he has taken on
as Florida Governor rubs me obviously
the wrong way I think it's immoral and
disgusting but the truth is DeSantis is
not stupid he's a highly educated guy
and it's hard to believe that DeSantis
would genuinely see Trump in a positive
light obviously de Santa sees Trump as a
[ __ ] and that is exactly what this
article says to Santos is saying behind
the scenes the article says so far the
DeSantis Trump's Smackdown has been
unfolding off camera but it likely won't
stay that way DeSantis and private
trashes Trump he calls him a TV
personality and a [ __ ] who has no
business running for president a former
DeSantis staffer said
DeSantis tells donors that if he takes
on Trump he would launch a full frontal
attack on his record incompetence
according to a republican Source briefed
on the conversation DeSantis says the
only way to beat Trump is to attack him
head-on he would he says he would turn
to Trump during a debate and say why
didn't you fire fauci you said you would
build the wall but there's no wall why
is that
sandis is not stupid okay my interest is
that both of these guys go down in
flames in 2024. so I say let him fight
I've been saying this for a while the
more
Trump hurts DeSantis the better the more
DeSantis hurts Trump the better at some
point one of these two is going to be
the front runner and whatever hits they
take from the other guy are going to
extend the Republican primary make it
uglier and hopefully turn people off of
voting from voting for Republicans
altogether
DeSantis has taken a lead in the betting
markets these are extraordinary numbers
now I want to remind everybody this is
not polling of who do you support this
is betting who do you believe will
eventually be the nominee DeSantis is
now leading Trump
this has not been the case for a while
and in fact if we look at the uh 90 day
let's see what are the numbers here
uh yes you see that sometime in early to
mid-august DeSantis equaled and then
surpassed Trump trump sort of came back
a little bit but now it is DeSantis
steadily in the lead in the betting
markets if you want to make a dollar
betting on Trump being the nominee
you've got to bet 29 cents and if you
want to make a dollar betting on
DeSantis being the nominee you've got
about 35 cents in other words since it
is considered more likely at this point
in the betting Market that DeSantis will
be the nominee you've got to put up more
money to make a dollar this is a really
big deal the SanDisk is building a lead
here now in terms of the behind the
scenes if I were to sandus I would be
trying to for for example maybe expedite
the investigations into Trump in
desantis's own State of Florida remember
Mar-A-Lago Trump's home is in Florida I
would be trying to secretly screw Trump
over by making the legal trouble as bad
as possible now maybe to see santis is
doing that but you have the Republican
Party having to walk what is essentially
a tightrope they can't turn on Trump
right now without losing Trump
supporters and it's too early for that
because Trump May indeed run
at the same time if they're too aligned
with Trump they risk going down with the
ship if Trump indeed gets indicted and
goes down and someone like the scientist
really Builds an actual polling lead
against Trump many of these presidential
elections even though the elector of the
popular vote difference is big I mean
millions and millions of votes that Joe
Biden won by in 2020 oftentimes the
Electoral margin comes from narrow
victories in just a handful or even two
or three states so it is a very fine
line that these Republicans are walking
my view as a concerned leftist is Let
Them Fight
Let them fight and let him make it as
filthy as possible Donald Trump gave an
interview yesterday and he again did
this bizarre n-word rant this is his new
bit he knows exactly who his audience is
and this was an interview in which
Donald Trump seemed very confused quite
disoriented take a listen if you look at
Putin with his talk
if you look at this is not talk you
don't mention that thing that thing that
we don't want to talk about I say the
n-word well it means the nuclear word
the n-word is the nuclear word and that
is a threat like nobody's had out there
I mean he's talking about that openly
and it's being handled very badly I
agree with you that shouldn't have
happened very badly from within Trump
knows exactly who his audience is
he knows exactly how to wind people oh
the n-word the n-word and you might
remember that clip from his rally over
the weekend where Trump brought up the
n-word and he goes you know what that is
and then the crowd thinks they know
which n-word he's talking about and then
Trump has to pacify them and go no no no
no no no I mean nuclear I mean nuclear
or nuclear as some like to say uh Donald
Trump seems to think that Putin is
winning in Ukraine despite a protracted
stalemate at best for Russia right now
Mr President if you get reelected let's
just say I'm hypothetically here you get
back in what would you do to broker
piece right away because I don't hear
anybody from the European Union and
definitely in the Biden regime trying to
convince these two zelinski and Putin to
get to the table and do what's right for
the innocent people die by the way
before Trump delivers his foreign policy
analysis this is on oan Trump is
increasingly relegated to being
interviewed on Newsmax and oan fox had
him last week to try to help him out but
he is increasingly not welcome on
mainstream networks in the middle which
is come to the peace marketing table
nobody's willing to discuss that
well it would have been much easier
before it happened but it did happen and
that's where we are right now the thing
you have to do is get the oil price down
and Russia will stop because Russia is
getting at a hundred dollars a barrel
Russia has never had they've never had
wealth like this before and despite the
war in the cost of the war what the war
is doing to everybody and the killing
the tremendous killing that's taking
place if you got oil down to you know I
had it down to forty dollars a barrel I
had it down to less than that we had
gasoline at one point remember the the
collapse in the oil Market was because
of covet now Trump is praising it like
it's a good thing down to a dollar and
49 cents can you believe it I remember
now you look at where it is you look at
where it is right now everybody was
buying very big cars and trucks they
were driving trucks they wanted not even
SUVs let's go buy a truck but we had it
down to a level that nobody's seen in
decades and decades and decades and it
was a great thing this country was
booming and then they shut it off but
what you do is you have to get the oil
price down you get the oil price down
the the uh you get it down to forty
fifty dollars a barrel the war would
stop automatically you don't even have
to talk to anybody would stop
automatically now of course this entire
framing is completely absurd Trump seems
to think Putin is actually winning in
Ukraine despite the reality on the
ground being dramatically different but
you're not going to get pushed back on
oan they're not they're certainly not
going to push back about that now one
interesting moment was that you know oan
is one of the most weaponized
disinformation audiences that is out
there in right-wing media on oam on oan
Trump stood by the vaccines for covid as
well as operation warp speed which I
don't know that the audience here is
necessarily going to love but remember
Trump is desperate to have something to
take credit for uh as far as uh
operation warp speed I mean I've been
given great reviews on that by a lot of
people we've done that we did an
incredible job you know what we handed
it back over after a rigged election we
handed it back over the stock market was
higher than it was prior to covet the
day before covet came in and by the way
the stock market is higher than it is
right now I don't know if anybody's
noticed that yeah we've lost 7 trillion
since Biden took over yeah I was going
to get to that in the economy but I
still got to get that vaccine question
Out Mr President just because I get so
many viewers asking with the side
effects where does Mr Trump stand on
that the the side effects guys the side
effects which are what again just flew
like a little bit so many viewers sent
that into me so we got a vaccine done
and we also got regeneron and a lot of
other therapeutic things done which
phenomenal in which remember Trump
didn't do any of those things the uh you
know people don't talk about but really
have been fantastic uh the vaccine was
done in nine months instead of five
years or ten years or 12 years and as
you know there are many many people that
think that millions of people worldwide
have been saved because of the for the
vaccine uh we'll see what happens we're
going we're looking at it very very
closely but we got that done in nine
months as opposed to five years to 12
years I said who's going to take
anywhere from five to twelve years Mr
President you would remove any type of
mandate at the federal level for our
military for first run for everybody
when it comes to this vaccine because
there are questions about the side
effects so you would like it there are
really no questions
I didn't do the mandates the mandates
were done by other people yep just
wanted to get you on the record for that
under me yeah so many Band-Aids were
done by Governors and they were done by
others and the mandates were very bad I
was against the mandates I was never for
the men all right so for you know he's
trying to court an audience on oan that
is not big on the vaccines that's the
reality and
um I don't know how that's going to
necessarily go over with them but Trump
has very little left and he just doesn't
even know where to go uh Donald Trump uh
continuing uh the theme from his rallies
of the anti-tran stuff during this
interview as well this thing has
exploded like it's okay and normal to
start cutting up a 13 or a 14 year old
and use 140 different genders and 200
different pronouns this is nonsense
they're going after our kids don't you
think Mr President
true and I ended that as you know I
ended it largely in the country but I
ended it for our military it was over
you couldn't do it right and there was a
little bit of fuss from a few people but
99 of the people agreed this is a very
this is an issue that if you ever took a
real poll it probably would pull at one
percent and they're trying to destroy
our country so this is now a theme this
is you know we started seeing this
actually at CPAC where the biggest
Applause lines were the overtly
homophobic and transphobic ones and
we're increasingly seeing this and it's
a really depressing thing to see absent
any actual policy last clip here
uh trumpers as well as Trump himself
want to paint a picture of the golden
age of America the summer of covet even
though it was actually the summer of
covid and we're not that far away we had
something going so special two years ago
we were leading the world in every
category every group within our country
was leading African-American Asian
American women men Hispanics everybody
was leading young people old people we
were all doing great yeah remember that
that was when hospitals needed to bring
in refrigerated trucks as morgues
because they were out of space for the
people dead from covet in the hospitals
another bizarre interview
completely disconnected from reality
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
well-truth social is very rapidly
heading towards bankruptcy and I
actually do like this but not because I
necessarily want to see it fail but
because it does confirm that the demand
that the right claims is there for some
completely unfettered free speech
platform for the right to be allowed to
say what they want really isn't there
there really isn't the demand for it so
let's back up a little bit truth social
is this right-wing social media platform
it's Donald Trump's social media
platform to some degree and the idea of
Truth social was all of the conservative
voices being censored on Twitter and
elsewhere you're going to be able to go
to truth social and you will be free to
say whatever you want everyone can say
whatever they want on Truth social turns
out number one
wasn't actually the case lots of people
getting banned on Truth social for
talking about the January 6 committee
hearings or for all bunch of different
things so it turns out it wasn't really
this free speech platform they claim it
would be secondly turns out it wasn't
really a platform too many people were
interested in and the latest sort of
nail in the coffin is that investors are
pulling almost 140 million dollars from
the company that is planning to merge
with Trump's truth social The Business
Insider article writes the deadline for
digital world to acquire Trump's truth
social past on September 20th investors
are walking away from planned
commitments of 140 million dollars
Reuters reports that Sabi management
investors bowed out taking away 100
million dollars this is going to likely
be the demise of Truth social and of
course as far as these investors go the
fact that they were going to invest in
the first Place shows that they're not
necessarily the most brilliant investors
many of the businesses that Trump is a
part of end up going under and investors
lose money Trump tries to run away with
the cash and it's a complete and total
disaster but I think the most important
the reason I love this is that they love
to say the entire right and you know
they claim sometimes they'll claim the
right is 225 million people Trump
recently said
75 million people voted for him
and that there's probably another 150
million trumpists as well the numbers
don't even make sense it's absurd
numbers if you look at how many adults
there are in the U.S makes no sense
whatsoever but their story is there's
tens of millions or hundreds of millions
of us we are being silenced on Twitter
and everywhere else and we really want a
platform where we can say what we want
and say what we believe and it's going
to be great and it's going to be
profitable and it's going to explode
they create truth social
and it just kind of goes nowhere and
what I love is that truth social is
failing in the marketplace of ideas
nobody's censoring truth social
nobody's shutting it down
but slowly but surely people don't care
they don't really have users and it just
declines and declines and declines and
it looks like ultimately it's going to
end up going under completely it will of
course be blamed on radical leftists
global-ish whatever but the reason it's
failing is because it's terrible and
it's even sort of like a Twitter clone
if you look at the platform the buttons
the read the retruth and all the entire
design and user interface it's basically
a Twitter clone and so if your belief is
Twitter on a technical level is fine but
it needs to be free from censorship of
conservatives then by definition truth
social should be doing really well it's
not it's not doing well and it's going
to go under and I absolutely love it hey
here is a story that I don't know if
you'll find this surprising I didn't
find it particularly surprising a new
book out explains that when Donald Trump
would see staffers of color at the White
House meaning non-white people he would
assume that they were waiters even
though they were not there's a really
good Rolling Stone article about this
which I encourage you to check out which
we will link to Trump saw staffers of
color at the White House and assumed
they were waiters when Democratic
leaders brought a racially diverse group
of staffers to a meeting the former
president assumed that they were there
to serve food oh my God like is it's
absurd but is it really that surprising
the article recounts an event in January
of 2017 when Trump had a reception with
top Congressional leaders there were
hors d'oeuvres and there were a bunch of
democratic staffers and apparently Trump
turned to them and asked them to bring
over some of the appetizers why don't
you get the food Trump told staffers for
Chuck Schumer
God it's making me cringe to even read
this Trump told staffers for Schumer
Pelosi and others
go and get the food
this is according to New York Times
Reporter Maggie haberman's new book
confidence man
then white house chief of staff rince
priebus rushed to correct Trump's remark
telling the then president that those
were top Congressional aides not White
House wait staff
Rolling Stone writes Trump's remark as
just one example of Trump's casual
racism detailed in the pages of
confidence man later in the same meeting
Trump told Schumer and Pelosi that
ballots cast by illegals were the only
reason he lost in 2016's popular vote to
Hillary
after an awkward silence Pelosi
interjected I don't believe so Mr
President oh my God
this is just wild
the book describes Trump's relationship
with Cara young a model he dated for
many years who had a black mother and a
white father after meeting Young's
parents Trump joked she got her beauty
from her mother and her intelligence
from her dad the white side Trump
laughed at his own joke young didn't and
according to the book voiced her
displeasure this is all just completely
nuts it's all completely nuts but also
completely unsurprising
um think back remember this incident
during Trump's 2016 campaign we had a
case where we had an African-American
guy who is a fan of mine great fan great
guy in fact I want to find out what's
going on with him you know what I'm look
at my African-American over here look at
him are you the greatest do you know
what I'm talking about okay
it's funny it's funny but it's also
absolutely horrifying and uh this
shouldn't really shock us remember that
Donald Trump paid for an ad in the
newspaper calling for the death of
innocent black people who had been
falsely accused of a crime it's called
the Central Park five and so I'm filing
the revelations in Maggie haberman's
book under things that we already
thought were probably true and now we
have definitive confirmation just
completely unbelievable we have a
voicemail number which is 2192 David P
now I want to address the question asked
in this voicemail seriously because many
of you have been asking it take a listen
hey David Chris from Portland yeah uh so
you know I really was hoping that you'd
be able to share with uh the listeners
the process that you go through to uh
vet some of these Republican candidates
that you have uh on your show that
you're interviewing because they almost
seem so consistently wacky yeah it's
like you're cherry picking them now I
know you're not but it seems like you
are because they're all just out there
uh so if you could explain the process
that you go through that'd be great as I
mean that person today Allison she
really did say it all yeah all right
thanks bye so listen many people have
written in and said David
why don't you interview the more
intelligent articulate and reasonable
Republicans running for 2022. why is
every person that you interview
completely whacked out of their gourd
here's the reality we cast an extremely
wide net very very wide net and I'm
looking now at emails from my colleague
John about all of the different people
that he approached it's dozens of
candidates dozens of candidates some of
them are more reasonable a couple weeks
ago I interviewed this guy Johnny Teague
who won the Republican primary in the
Texas Seventh District and he might
believe JFK Jr is still alive fine but
he he was more reasonable at least in
terms of some of his political views we
cast a really wide net most of these
Republicans don't want to be interviewed
by me I think many of them research us
and they look at past interviews I've
done and they turn us down I've also
told you that we've had probably five or
six who have initially agreed to be
interviewed and then something happens
between when they agree and the day of
the interview and they bail we literally
never hear from them again in many cases
they just they don't show up they're not
on Skype when we're supposed to be
interviewing them we never get an
explanation so some of them bail because
of that so what you are seeing is not me
cherry-picking the craziest Republican
candidates it's these are just the ones
that are ending up on the show for one
reason or another and some of them are
completely out of their minds like
Allison Hayden yesterday she was really
nuts scary scary nuts in a way on the
other hand we also have other candidates
who have just not shown up so we really
are trying to get a diverse
representation education of what is
going on on the Republican side right
now and listen Johnny Teague was more
reasonable Allison Hayden was more
Bonkers and you know John Gibbs was I
guess somewhere in between or something
like that but we are not cherry picking
and so many foot people you know
sometimes people say David why won't you
debate Ben Shapiro
I've had Ben Shapiro on and we've
invited him many times and he doesn't
accept coming on now you can say well
that's because your show isn't big
enough to be worth it for him fine but
don't tell me I'm unwilling you can't
say David you're unwilling
and then I explain he's welcome and then
you say well yeah why would he do your
show okay but the point was I'm willing
I'm willing that's the situation we're
not cherry-picking the crazies but I
think it Bears mentioning that a lot of
the Republicans running this year are
completely nuts
we have a great bonus show for you today
the British pound has plummeted to a
record low against the dollar we will
talk about the implications and the
reasons and more I am going to weigh in
on the chess
crisis wherein top player Magnus Carlson
has accused another player named Hans
Neiman of cheating it has taken the
Chess World by storm and we will talk
about it and also Brazilians are about
to vote
and there are viral election lies
there's a lot of trumpy stuff being said
by bolsonaro all of which we will talk
about on today's bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad yeah listen the bonus
show is great I would love for you to
sign up at joinpakman.com get access get
in there it's going to be an absolutely
fantastic thing we'll talk to you very
soon join pacman.com coupon code indict
gets you a discount
thank you